which brings me to nailed it the next
little bit of fun we have
for tonight oh boy my friends we are
going on a wild ride
i hope i i imagine some of you may be
fans of like i don't know uh james bond
right james bond movies spy thrillers
you know what movies i like the fast and
the furious movies yeah
yeah senseless explosions and like for
some reason
car thieves are important and the
government wants them to like
stop terrorism and car chases and
whatnot yeah yeah
i have no idea why the government came
to a car thief from brooklyn or whatever
miami and asked him to like
stop a terrorist lady with a helicopter
and a submarine but hey man
sometimes these stores are just fun but
what happens when there's no movie
theaters because they're shut down
you get this oh cassandra of troy now
who is this lady
i don't know but she wrote the more i
write about this
the more it becomes plain if biden loses
2020 will be the last
remotely free and fair election we have
for decades
and certainly my lifetime we are in the
middle of an autocratic attempt
and it looks so much like hungaries the
courts are being packed with loyalists
most state legislatures and swing states
are gerrymandered beyond belief
the executive branch is gaining unitary
power the department of justice is
blatantly selectively applying the law
to favor the autocrat
igs are being destroyed oh there's more
i'm going to read it how many pounds
is 10. 10 of these okay anyway to drop
the uh
the funny action the point this is this
has got 26 000 retweets
but why because people need james bond
to be real they're really boring they
need trump to walk in the room
holding a cat stroking it and joe biden
to like
swing down from like a cable and go ha
ha well chap time to take you out
and then you know donald trump is like
get him kitty and the cat's made of gold
and the cat turns into a robot
they need something exciting because
life is boring yeah
so they write unhinged paranoid
delusional trash like this let's read on
oh yeah
she says ags are being replaced congress
is no longer a check on corruption
as the senate has been captured by trump
loyalists
ruth bader ginsburg is in bad shape
ditto breyer
hybrid regimes competitive
authoritarianism are remarkably stable
this is why 2020 is for all the marbles
this is why i have no use for people who
whinge about biden harris not being far
enough left for their tastes
they are under the mistaken belief that
if biden loses they will have another
chance to elect people that are far
enough left for their liking
the truth is and here we go if biden and
harris lose
there isn't going to be an opportunity
to elect someone like
they like in their lifetime not without
secession of blue states
that's the only plausible scenario i can
come up with
after the autocratic breakthrough the
people who study autocracy are all
singing the same tune
american democracy is not strong enough
to survive another four years it's four
years
dude come on the the tv shows last
longer than that
the guard rails are already almost
completely down this is entirely
consistent
with how others have fallen in the
post-cold war period
trump's intentions are clear so are the
gops while republicans are fearmongering
the hell out of this election
democrats refuse to call what is
happening what it is for fear of
sounding alarmist
maybe this helps their chances of
election but it leaves the vast majority
of the american public in the dark
as to how incredibly dangerous this
moment is
especially with q anon a group that
wants enemies thrown in concentration
camps
inexorably capturing the republican
party even as it becomes autocratic
beware be warned or don't because once
this election comes and goes
if donald j trump is still president on
january 21st
2021 we're aft democracy in america is
not coming back dun dun dun cue the
crazy music and the explosions and you
got yourself a kind of thriller man this
is great
yeah i love it she she finishes with in
most states your vote no longer matters
we are rapidly approaching it at a
federal level you
know that you no long you are no longer
living a democracy
because the elections in which you are
participating no longer can yield
political change
and um i don't know where's the you know
those boxes where they pull the lever
like the wiley
while you like while e coyote would use
and like it would blow
up yep the detonation box cue that as
soon as she finishes like
jira oh yeah i'm thinking she took an
entire bottle of painkillers after dude
i would
holy cow i got a really good idea it'd
be fun to like make a movie trailer with
this yeah
just read this and like you know you
know how they do the movie trailers
where the guy sounds like he's been
smoking for 40 years
the more i write about this the more it
becomes plain if biden loses
2020 will be the last remotely free and
fair election we have had for decades
all right alex jones i know i was
thinking that like i should probably
read this in alex jones voice yeah
except even jones isn't that that's the
same people no
no no no alex jones isn't i mean he's
screaming about other
other people but he's not like talking
about trump being a dictator
oh my gosh the best the best part about
all of this is that this this this world
view they've crafted is
they're building a tower someone imagine
it right it's like uh
you know rachel mata goes on tv and
she's like you know
donald trump is a russian when that
falls apart what do they do with that
mound of trash they've built for three
years
listen if you built a nice house
you'd love and you'd respect that house
and you'd say i like this building
now if you built a big pile of trash to
stand on
you might not like it like a house but
you're like hey man
i built this pile of trash this is my
garbage my garbage that's right
don't touch my garbage like that that
possum meme
don't touch my garbage you know as much
as i'm not really all that interested in
the garbage i can understand why someone
you know spending three years piling up
garbage would be like i know it's
garbage but i did put a lot into this
it's exactly like a sunken cost fallacy
right they put all their time into this
and gosh darn it it is the best garbage
in the world
so here's what ends up happening i've
built you know
many of us those of you watching we've
all built nice little houses of like a
coherent thought
donald trump has his issues but for the
most part you know he's okay
and and he's doing a lot of things that
have been traditional in terms of like
political parties some people have
compared him to like bill clinton in the
good way not the bad way like
you know just general populist policy
and stuff
although i will say i i think trump is
very very different from bill clinton
but some people have said like in terms
of where he sits
on the political spectrum it's
relatively similar
and the things he says you know are very
inviting to regular people
so we've all built these kind of little
huts of coherent thought but the left is
sitting on a big pile of stinky garbage
they refuse to let go because they've
put too much into it and they keep
inviting more people
to the stinky garbage and they're
warning like so here's what happens
you're walking down the street there's a
fork in the road and there's a bunch of
nice little looking huts
but there's that big old pile of garbage
and there's someone sitting at the fork
telling you go to the garbage pile
this woman clearly does and then she's
staring at like old faded cans of like
pepsi from the 70s
and she's reading the ingredients and
screaming did you know what's in this
and then like i'm actually i'll do a
better example with this pile of garbage
you'll have like someone find an old you
know um i don't know
uh a a she a piece of like a building
and there's asbestos on it
and so they start screaming about the
asbestos but nobody's using it anymore
right it's gone it's been removed you
know there's a lot of problems with it
these people who have built their
garbage pile have bad information
things that make no sense and the
narrative of russia and all this
conspiracy stuff about trump is just
not true how insane do you have to be to
believe
that nationally out of like how many how
many political offices
are there in this country like five or
seven thousand uh yeah many many many
that they're all being secretly taken
over and that
trump controls them all this requires a
lot of faith yeah
it's nuts yeah even even as it goes with
like when it comes to the democrats and
mail and voting
i don't think they're they're all
sitting there like a cabal but
i'll tell you this i think it's really
funny that she brought up q anon
because q people not all of i don't i
think a lot of people who follow q
don't actually read what it's all about
and so there's a lot of people have a
general view of what it means like you
know epstein and stuff like that
which like we know the epstein stuff is
like mostly true because victims have
come
come forward and there's you know we'll
see what happens with that maxwell lady
but like bill clinton has been flight
logs not to the island but there's like
there's weird stuff there's weird
there's weird stuff around there right
so it's like okay but some of these
people go nuts
like they think conspiracies go way too
far but it's funny that she brings up q
because she's like
the other side of that you know trump
trump anon or whatever or
c clinton anon i don't know whatever tds
lady yeah
do you think she realizes that she
sounds exactly as deranged no
or more so no the reason why she brings
up q
is because when she looks across the
aisle that's what she sees
yeah like she's on the same level she's
the inversion of it yeah got it so but
think about it if the queue people think
there's like a government cabal
conspiracy and like trafficking and all
the stuff
and she's claiming that trump is an
autocrat who's like stacking the courts
and like going
i work for russia it's just as insane
yep i think i think hillary clinton and
and her
and her uh you know cronies like the
people around her
they're just crooks i i think that
they've probably been involved in really
bad stuff i think it's questionable what
bill clinton was doing with epstein and
i think there may be something there
we'll look into
but i don't think there's like a grand
international illuminati cabal like
you know snatching up kids or anything
like that i mean you know but at least
it's based in reality i suppose that
would be too easy
too simple too interesting to pat that
makes me think it's not real
well i think i think there's something
with epstein and clinton yeah for sure
and there's been
and prince andrew but but i think a lot
of people probably take that and then
immediately assume
like extreme scenarios like everything
else go there look i think i think
you know we know that politicians are
creepy weirdos who do drugs and probably
do illegal things like all the time for
sure
but to to go as insane as this lady
when it's like listen i think hillary
clinton was bad for a lot of reasons
i think she was very crooked and i think
joe biden is crooked i think donald
trump has some questionable things and
criticized him for but for the most part
it's in the same realm of like politics
in this country
and i think trump does love this [ __ ]
does love this country and i think he is
a populist though he is himself very
elite
i don't think he's all that bad and i
think they're extreme in their
exaggerations of who he is
and i think a lot of people are extreme
in their exaggerations of who hillary
clinton is yep hillary clinton is a
crooked cronyist
who played dirty with cash at a
foundation and a bunch of other
horrifying things
and that's corruption at the highest
level yep and that's
i'm like yeah that's the thing what else
is new yeah
unfortunately i don't think she's like
meeting in the basements with like giant
owl statues and like praying to like
pentagrams or anything like that again
way too interesting
yeah right now he's very boring really
super often
i mean i mean look you know that's
that's why i was kind of saying like
what this lady
is saying with this trump conspiracy
you'd think after all these years they'd
let go
it's just not real trump is not a secret
agent
trump is not like kaiser what's what's
the
what was the guy's name um what's the
what was the world war
treasure wilhelm not wilhelm i don't
know um
no no no no i'm not thinking of kaiser
wilhelm i'm thinking of um
that that autocratic german dude i can't
remember his name
that's on the tip of my tongue i'm sorry
he's he's one of the guys who said it is
better that 10 innocent people suffer
than one guilty person escape
what was his name i don't know
everyone's gonna everyone's gonna like
know his name now in a second that was
blackstone
no no no blackstone blackstone was the
inverse he said it's better that ten
innocent uh ten guilt uh ten guilty
people escape than one innocent suffered
innocent oh snap yeah so there this this
other guy
i can't remember his name not not people
are saying kaiser says no no no no
um maybe i'm thinking maybe it wasn't
the german guy
bismarck bismarck there you go
who is he am i mixing his up him up with
somebody else i think i
am anyway anyway
yeah where where was he because he was
the authoritarian guy
you know he was a decisive figure in
european history he retained control
over prussia prussia
there we go see i have no idea what i'm
talking about but i had a general idea
yeah i read something on the internet
once yes
no but here's it this is why i'm not
going to write an article about bismarck
i don't know i'm a fact check at first
you know what i mean yeah absolutely
and and i do this whenever i say
something i'm not sure i'll tell people
make sure you factor because i heard
this i don't know if it's true
but it's you know it's interesting
nonetheless a lot of people just write
garbage but like
they think donald trump is you know like
having secret meetings and bunkers
about like with like pulling out maps
and then like as soon as trump walks
downstairs he pulls off like a fake flap
of skin and there's a mustache
and then he starts speaking with like
they think donald trump is secretly a
dictator trying to take over the world
they've watched too many movies
yes donald trump is like wearing his
personality
on his sleeve like he can't accept that
he is a boisterous egotistical
tv personality reality a rally tv real
estate mogul
who he loves america he he does
international trade deals and he thought
he could do better than everybody else
and he knows people and he won and he
made the economy
work really really well but he didn't
really understand how government works
because he's not a politician
yep so he did some things wrong he hired
some bad people
and i think he's starting to figure out
and do a better job he's a smart guy
i think it's i think it's crazy when
they call him stupid you got to be you
got to be you got to be
arrogant beyond all recognition to
assume someone like donald trump is
stupid that is insanely wishful thinking
to think that donald trump is stupid
impulsive
maybe arrogant sure but the guy like
i i think it's hilarious when they say
things like his unsuccessful business
whenever i hear my friend say something
like that i'm like which one and they're
like the one he declared bankruptcy on
i'm like
okay first of all which one second of
all
he had like 500 plus businesses and
declared bankruptcy like a handful of
times
and bankruptcy doesn't even mean you
failed it's like debt protection
so like which one they don't even know
do they
i once had a bottle of trump water and a
trump stake and they and they were
complaining in the media that time that
the companies were defunct
and i'm like trump's companies like
trump magazine
and trump water they service his
properties
so they were they were saying like all
these things failed and i'm like no he
just sells them he like
it's a company he makes it then he sells
it to his own company right
but they're they're they're too obsessed
with
their like movie reality world and i
have to wonder
there are some people on twitter who are
unhinged and normally i say that you
know kind of
in in an exaggerated tone no some of
these people are literally
mentally ill not kidding they're i'm not
going to name i'm not going to name
these specific individuals because i
don't want to you know
i don't want to send on i don't want to
send people over to these mentally ill
profiles
but there are some twitter people with
hundreds of thousands of followers who
are quite literally
mentally ill to be fair there
are a lot of people on twitter and
statistically speaking some of them are
likely to be mentally ill and frankly
twitter kind of caters to the
obsessive compulsive tendencies and
makes people
stirred up into a crazy neurodivergent
yeah i remember
like someone recently asked me like what
does that mean what is neurodivergent
and i'm like
it is the tumbler way of saying you you
are mentally ill
yes neurodivergent really just means
your brain goes in two different
directions
or it goes in the wrong direction yep
all of the wrongdoing there there are
some people who've tweeted like
really really crazy things saying things
like
steve bannon is going to be hanged for
treason or something
no joke interesting yeah i'm not going
to name these people but again too many
movies i'm sure everybody knows who i'm
talking about right now
but they're admittedly mentally ill
what's what's crazy is twitter verifies
them
and listen you gotta understand
is that if i come to you and say um do
you wanna go to the park
and you go why what's happening at the
park i don't know like i don't know
someone would like a dog was there
you'll be like dogs are cool but
that sounds kind of boring yeah what if
i walked in and said dude we gotta go to
the park why
there's like clowns and like a giraffe
came in and then like some dude was
juggling knives and those like flame
throwers
like whoa whoa whoa what yeah
flamethrowers dude come on you'd be like
okay okay okay let's go to the park
right then you go there's nothing there
so what's happening is these people on
twitter
some people will be like donald trump
today you know said he wants to uh uh
build houses in low-income areas or
whatever
and then you're like uh-huh okay yeah i
don't know whatever is that news
nobody clicks it yep so what do they
have to do uh donald trump who was
uh hitler wants to build
homes to
force impoverished people
into internment oh oh snap
and then people are like whoa and they
click it and then they go to the article
and it's like the housing and
development project for
the other less fortunate second but you
already gave them your click that's
that's the framing thing they do yeah
and then women like this the cassandra
lady who's like donald trump is an
autocrat trying to take over and we'll
never have an election again it's like
whoa
lady calm down i would i would make a
joke about taking some kind of
medication but this is a
show with a lot of people and i might
get in trouble for doing so but in a in
a normal
private setting i'd make a ton of jokes
about medication i probably already made
too many jokes
yeah it sounds like she's about to go
over the edge poor lady here's the
funniest thing about it
check out the story from the daily
caller judge orders an iowa county to
invalidate
50 000 absentee ballot requests
oh huh how about that
let's just read this and i'm like it's
the exact opposite of everything they're
claiming about trump i thought this was
all without
evidence timothy why are they
invalidating 50 000 absentee ballot
requests
let's find out lynn county auditor joel
miller issued 140 000
absentee ballots in july that were
already pre-filled with voters personal
information
such as their date of birth and most
importantly voter identification numbers
according to the ap miller said he
wanted to make it easy for voters to
vote absentee during the pandemic per
the same report
however judge ian thornhill ruled that
miller's mailing of the ballots violated
a clear directive from iowa secretary of
state paul pate
who said absentee ballots forms must be
blank when sent to voters according to
the ap
thornhill has ordered miller to notify
voters who received pre-filled out
ballot
their ballot cannot be processed instead
they can either vote in person on
election day or request
new absentee ballots miller has agreed
to send the new blank forms
so it's actually not what we thought it
was but it's still kind of fraud
yeah the initial fraud it seemed like or
it you know impropriety was that
people were sending in their requests
and getting you know getting nuked
right as it turns out somebody was
trying to send out pre-filled forms to
people
so that seems shady does it seem shitty
to you because it seems like if he was
doing that in good faith
i understand wanting to make voting as
easy as possible no way
you don't think he was acting in good
faith i don't okay
because what so listen sitting right in
front of me i love pointing to this
thing it's still there
is a is a mailing ballot i know what to
do not an application
literal ballot that came to my house for
someone who does not live here
what if they filled out that person's
personal information including voter id
number
we have all their information now and
what would happen if some hokey old dumb
lady
you know she goes to her mailbox she's
like oh what's this
well for who i can't read it and she
opens it wrongly
and then she's looking through it and
she's like who's jimmy
what's this social security number and
bank account information
let me just punch this into amazon and
no i'm going to order some books
i'm kidding but uh if so if they send
out all that pre-fill that information
that's true that's that's a big breach
there's a lot of people probably get
mail and just tear it all up without
looking at it
you know they're like going through
bills they got a stack and they're
ripping things open especially if it's
like a married couple
and they're like the mail is just to
them the kids are moved out yeah they're
gonna get someone's mail they're gonna
open and be like
john smith voter id number whoa what
what is this
now they're gonna have their private
information yep
so presumably you know we get this
ballot sent here because this person
used to live here
that would be the same thing that would
happen to them but they would get access
to other information they'd have their
name and their voter id number
i don't know what else would be included
in it party affiliation maybe or
something i don't think so
well that's dirty so so here's why i
bring this one up because
they like to play this game where
they're accusing donald trump of being
the fraudster who's trying to take over
the world or whatever
and the problems are coming from their
demands it's it's been this way the
entire time
you know donald trump has made his
mistakes in fighting him but he's won
i think about like russia gate really is
crazy the obama gate stuff the russian
stuff so basically they've been they
were accusing trump of working for the
russians they wouldn't stop
and then trump made the mistake of
saying can you make it go away
and then firing comey can you blame him
for wanting it no
and he's allowed to do that he was
allowed to fire comey and then they went
nuts
and they were like screeching and they
won't stop but you know what
based on what we're talking about
earlier you know what i think it is
our our sphere of influence on the
internet is growing
and the establishment serious sphere of
influence is shrinking and they're
crying and panicking about it and
there's nothing they can do but i tell
you
as they drown they will violently thrash
about i'm seeing it
and they got you know kitty's got claws
man yeah so if you
i'll tell you this when you see someone
drowning don't you you have to be very
careful about how you approach them
because they will pull you down too yep
what do you what i'm not an expert but
you go around behind them yeah i think
you come up behind them and grab them
yeah and then swim backwards
but if you go up to them and they grab
you they'll just pull you down and
you'll both drown because they're
freaking out
that's what the mainstream media is
doing right now and that's why all these
personalities on twitter are going like
trump's a dictator
and then they go home and they're
shaking as they pour wine and they're
like
so much wine i'm imagining like when i
when i do that wine shaking i'm
imagining it's alyssa milano
she's like orange man he's orange and
the orange thing is
a real no you're laughing but she
actually i know she actually did it
i know she's not sorry that he's orange
or whatever
he's not sorry that he's orange the
funniest sorry alyssa
she tweeted out this big long unhinged
thread where she's like joe rogan has
three times the viewers that i do and
i'm like
do you mean like three orders of
magnitude yes that's what she meant
three times no we have three times
listeners
no we have more than that oh my goodness
we have way more than that okay dude she
doesn't even
even chart she's not even on any charts
she probably gets like 100 downloads
i'm not even kidding like i don't think
well no that's not fair she does have a
few thousand reviews so
you know maybe she's getting i don't
know a few thousand maybe
but anyway one of her tweets was like in
all caps he's orange and it's part of
his strategy to be orange and they don't
care
and i'm like what i don't care
it's part of the brand it's the orange
come on he's not like he
okay you've seen how they try to make
him look more orange right oh yeah
it's like one there was one that was
really funny where he was literally
glowing
and i'm like dude okay you guys
definitely overdid this because the
dude's not radioactive
was that the one where he was walking
towards the plane and his hair was
blowing back
no but that one was bad like easy
and it looked like it yeah they made
them look like a clown yeah so
weird they like desaturated around him
yeah no there was it was one where it
was like i think it was cnn or something
and he was literally glowing because
they up the saturation
too much i gotta find it now and i'm
just like uh
like i'm pretty sure donald trump's skin
isn't radioactive
cause like i don't know i don't i don't
know what generates an orange glow
but i'm assuming it's some kind of
quantum function pertaining to
radioactivity no one should be glowing
no but that's that's that's the media
man
they're they it it's it's funny when you
look at like
cnn's personalities like uh oliver darcy
and um oh man what did he tweet
what did darcy tweet today that like the
the right-wing media
and like kyle right now is a proof of
radicalization yeah
and i'm like but three months of mass
writing and 30 people dead that's not
radicalization yeah that wouldn't
ratifies anyone
but think about it it's like three
months
non-stop riots 30 people dead crickets
one guy shows up after three months two
people die
and they're screaming at the top of
their lungs fire
yeah yeah well my favorite was from
brian stelter
because he was railing about how much i
think it was
tucker carlson makes so you want to know
what i did
i did a little google search how much
does brian stelter make
you know how much brian stelter makes i
do tell me exactly how much he was
accusing
uh yeah brian seltzer how much is that
so he was accusing tucker carls i think
it was tucker carlson he was saying he
makes 10 million dollars a year
i was like okay that seems low first of
all let's see how much uh brian stelter
makes so
brian stelter makes 10 million no
i don't buy that weird i don't believe i
looked it up no way
i got ryan stelter on on cnn's lowest
rated show
versus the highest rated cable tv news
show in history
let me see it's possible i'll tell you
what tucker carlson signed a contract
and he probably got a lower number
because it was a new show yeah
i'll tell you this when tucker
renegotiates he's going to be the
highest made highest-paid man in
television
here's an article from cnn as tucker
carlson justifies violence fox news is
paying him 10 million dollars a year
wow yeah but is brian selter really
getting 10 million here i don't buy it
man
i found it google said it it's on the
internet it's true
maybe maybe i mean but you know cnn's
been downsizing
yeah that's a lot of money for a sunday
morning
show on the news like yeah his show is
about the news
yeah and it's funny because he only ever
has on like people in his bubble who say
the exact same things to each other
it's like literally listening to echoes
it's like listening to pokemon
like yeah so it's like if you took like
a bunch of pokemon and all they did was
sit in a room and sing their names over
and over again
like there's no meaningful conversation
i guess if you're a pokemon
and you like hearing someone say pikachu
seven thousand times that sounds like
fun
but it's really funny when you compare
like
the the style of a lot of these shows on
like msnbc or cnn
versus any podcast and i mean even
small podcasts where they'll have like i
don't care
you could take a random two random
people and have them talk
random off the street here's a good idea
for men on the street take a random guy
and another random guy and then have him
talk about politics yeah that would be
way more interesting and informative
than anything those people are doing on
sunday morning you know
cnn show true they're like did you see
that donald trump is a fascist
i did and the right wing media is lying
i know the right-wing media did you see
fox news what they said fox news did say
things
the duke news reviews ryan stelter wrote
a book about fox news
wow you know what i think that's his
world i think brian stelter wishes he
worked for fox news
it's like really sad it reminds me that
episode of the simpsons
where homer tries to join join the club
but they call it the no homers club oh
no and then he's like but you let in the
other homer and they're like it's the no
homers
we're allowed to have one yeah yeah so
it's like then he joins the freemasons
so it's like brian stelter sitting
outside of fox and he was going like fox
news is so dumb they didn't even do
anything
and he's like looking at the fox news
and like a tear rolls down his cheek
he's like i want to go inside fox news
he never quite cut it
no i don't think the guy ever really
wanted to work for fox news i think
he he was a media reporter for new york
times i guess he interviewed me back in
the day
really yeah for new york for the new
york times and that's the same age
yeah so weird yeah yeah he seemed like a
grandma
you seem like a skater dude i know
you're totally it's like
i gotta say it may have something to do
with the fact that i exercise
every day yeah and uh and um i'm going
to go ahead and assume he doesn't
yep that seems he should yep and i'm
pretty sure absolutely everybody should
yeah i i don't mean that as a dick i
mean that as uh
you know staying fit makes you look
younger yeah i mean not only that but
like
i dress like something you do dress
younger
i don't wear a suit or anything if i
wore a suit people would be like who's
that strange man
no my real criticism is about the fact
that they've made a whole show based on
just fox news and it's like listen i
understand i have my biases i rag on cnn
too but i reckon msnbc and abc in the
new york times in the washington post
and the democrats all of them and if you
want to brag on the republicans i
totally get it i'm down like
i i think you know i have my criticisms
of some of the progressive
and left-wing pundits on youtube for
sure but i respect what they do
they don't like republicans i get it i
don't like them either but my focus lies
elsewhere elsewhere
yeah i don't think the biggest threat to
our to our nation is donald trump
and there are pundits on on youtube who
don't think the world is ending either
i mean i think we're facing dire straits
don't get me wrong i don't think the
world is gonna explode and donald trump
is literally hitler
but i think we're gonna face like real
street violence and chaos and stuff like
that
but there are other lefting pundits who
will just be like trump is bad we should
vote for somebody else because policy
reasons
but you turn on msnbc and rachel
maddow's like russia
is going to turn off our electricity and
i'm like wow rachel
that was so deep up your that's uh
that's a way out there yes you had to
pull reach into that magic hat and pull
it out and
oh that magic hat pulling random stuff
out uh
i remember when donald trump said that
she had blood coming out of her eyes and
ears or her whatever and they turned it
into like
remember that yeah and i'm like dude he
didn't say it he stopped himself and you
don't know what he was going to say
out of her eyes and her ears out of her
whatever and they turned it into a
sexual thing
yeah that's so dumb so it's all so
tiresome
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you